but you have over the 18 seasons a
favorite twist and then a least favorite
ok well the least favorite would be the
the take over I have a few favorites I
really liked season four when we threw
win ex-boyfriends and ex-girlfriends
that was very interesting I also loved
of the few times we've had a twin twist
so you have to try to be me it's like
you're not playing you you're being me I
know Liz but I I know it's hard for you
because you're not you need to put your
hair up I think they should do a season
where they throw in like a bunch of
young hot single people you know and
after everyone's posturing imposing then
you throw in those people's mothers and
then their game is over everyone's too
afraid to do anything yes I would watch
that what previous choice do you think
needs a do-over but maybe didn't work
the first time I could work again I
think that exes twist would work well if
everybody had an ex in there
yes is that season it was only I think
four it was just a handful wasn't
everybody right because in a twist we
call The X Factor
five of you will be soon joined by your
ex-boyfriends or ex-girlfriends 10 of my
what have to go tell me that wrong
hey hey big brother hey you in which
house guests from previous seasons do
you think need a do-over would you like
to see back in the game
I would like to see Janel get another
shot because she's one of the best
players we've ever had and she's a fan
favorite and she was um she played it
honestly openly she didn't suck up to
people that she didn't like she won
competitions fair and square I think she
deserves a win and another chance